on a toujours le sentiment qu'il y a 5
ans qu'il y a 10 ans qu'il y a 30 ans
que la guerre froide était plus stable
c'était plus prévisible c'était je
rappelle les certains d'entre vous le
savent bien que ce n'est pas du tout le
sentiment qu'on avait à l'époque pendant
la guerre froide donc je crois que c'est
toujours un premier point à rappeler
parce que cela nous conduit
naturellement cette erreur à mon sens à
tomber dans un deuxième piège qui lui
dit il faut faire toujours plus et que
les fameux 2% ne suffisent évidemment
pas et là je suis méfiant vis-à-vis de
cette notion un double égard d'abord
parce que je déteste le critère de 2%,
je pense qu'il n'a aucun sens
pour de multiples raisons sur lesquelles
on pourrait revenir mais je suis sûr je
sais d'ailleurs que certains d'entre
vous ont déjà travaillé et ensuite parce
que aujourd'hui il me semble difficile à
nos concitoyens d'accepter beaucoup plus
que ce qui est aujourd'hui envisagé par
nos autorités politiques la notion
d'acceptabilité sociale de sociétal de
l'effort de défense dans le contexte que
nous connaissons doit être mesuré à
l'aune de ce que nous voulons avoir
comme esprit de défense et l'esprit
défense au sens le plus large du terme
et donc je me méfie énormément je ne
suis pas connu comme étant un ennemi des
armées mais je me méfie énormément du
toujours plus dans
dans ce